voilà dans un instant on sera en ligne
avec dijon où nicolas sarkozy tient son
premier meeting de deuxième tour de la
campagne du deuxième tour avec nous
françois fillon je le disais qu'on
présente parfois comme le possible
premier ministre nicolas sarkozy en cas
de victoire
qu'est ce qui doit changer dans son
discours après ce premier tour françois
fillon il faut que nicolas sarkozy c'est
que ce s'adresse à tous les français
il n'y a pas j'entendais tout à leur
dire sur votre antenne françois bayrou
détient la clé de cette élection non
dans une élection présidentielle n'y a
pas des français est dictée du df de
gauche il faut que nicolas sarkozy parle
à tous les français il va le faire il va
le faire avec le projet qui est le sien
sans modifier les orientations de ce
projet parce que ça ne serait pas
honnête ça ne serait pas mort à l'emploi
y aurait-il un changement il va montrer
d'abord que dans son projet il ya ceux
il ya une simplification au premier tour
elle est d'autant plus forte qu'il ya eu
un matraquage un peu dur d autre
candidat contre nicolas sarkozy donc il
va montrer qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
dans son projet qui correspondent à des
engagements qui étaient pris par
françois bayrou sur la modernisation des
institutions sur des réformes à
caractère économique ou des cailloux à
caractère social il ya beaucoup de
choses qui reprennent les mêmes il
excelle peut résumer ça en disant pour
le premier tour il est allé sur les
terres de jean marie le pen devant ses
électeurs pour le deuxième tour il va
aller sur les ordures ans en arrière
lorsque son projet sera le même et vous
verrez que vous ne trouverez pas de deux
choses nouvelles dans le projet de
nicolas sarkozy il ne va pas inventer
des idées nouvelles qui ne seraient pas
des idées qui correspondrait à ses
engagements au travail que nous avons
fait pendant deux ans pour essayer de
réfléchir à la manière de sortir la
france de la crise simplement il va
rassembler sur son projet et vous verrez
que son projet répond à a beaucoup
d'attentes des français qui souhaitent
gauche d euros qu'ils soient du centre
alors on poursuit cet entretien françois
fillon